John: Hank, I'm here with the lovely Cara
Delevingne.
Cara: And I'm here with lovely John Green.
John: That was a pretty good imitation.
Cara: I know.
John: You play Margo in the movie and I'm
gonna ask you real questions by real nerdfighters.
What's it like to kiss Nat?
Cara: Oh.
*laughs* Yeah, he's a good kisser.
He's a really good kisser.
I was actually talking about him with a friend
of mine who's also kissed him.
And we had a whole conversation about how
he was a good kisser.
Surprisingly good!
John: I wonder what friend that could be.
Cara: *shhhhh*
John: I'm just kidding I know.
Cara: Do you?
John: Yeah.
Is Margo someone that you can relate to?
And how?
Cara: Very much so.
I think that's why I got the part because
a lot of the stories that she went through
in the book and all those kind of things,
I've been through before and a lot of the
lines they've actually written in the script
I've said before.
She runs on instinct.
She does what she feels in the moment and
doesn't really think about the consequences.
John: And you're like that too.
Cara: Yeah.
John: Are you an octopus?
Cara: Obviously.
John: Is John a good executive producer?
Cara: No.
John: It's true.
Cara: *laughs* He is.
John: What do I do as an executive producer?
Cara: You are so fun.
*laughs*
John: What is John like in real life?
Is he just like in the videos?
Cara: I would say so.
Yeah, you're... but I think you're even funnier
in real life, because you edit out all the
beautifulness.
John: I knew a face touch was coming.
I knew I wasn't gonna get out of this video
without some kind of face touch.
Bacon or Nutella?
Cara: That's so hard.
Both.
John: What is your opinion of my eyebrows?
Cara: I thought they'd be less coarse and
they're actually nice.
They're good, they're a good texture.
John: But they're not as good as yours.
Cara: What?
John: Well I mean, you have famous eyebrows.
Literally.
You maybe have the most famous eyebrows on
Earth right now.
Cara: No.
John: Who?
Yeah you can't even think of someone.
It's you!
Have you read the book Paper Towns?
Cara: No.
John: Yes you have.
Cara: Of course I have.
It was really good.
I really liked it.
I didn't actually...yeah, I didn't know how
good you were.
*laughs*
John: *laughs* Thanks man.
Cara: I thought you were gonna be - not to
be rude - but like younger because you do
it from a young person's perspective so well.
John: But I am in fact really old.
Cara: You are.
John: What is your favorite word?
Cara: My favorite word and my least favorite
word in one is regime.
John: How did you feel when you found out
you'd been cast for this?
Cara: I cried.
I remember where I was, like the whole thing.
I just remember freaking the freak out.
John: Where were you?
Cara: I was actually by myself, which is a
bit sad, but I was in a hotel room getting
ready for work, and I got called, and I just
started crying.
It was too much.
John: I knew that you were gonna get it from
when I watched your audition.
Cara: Really?
John: Yeah.
Cara: That's so nice.
John: What do you want to be when you grow
up?
Cara: President.
Prime Minister.
An astronaut!
John: An astronaut Prime Minister.
Cara: An alien-fighting Princess Peach with
steroid injecting angel gun with wings.
On a unicorn!
Multi-colored.
With golden eyes.
John: That's good.
That's detailed.
Someone is gonna draw that.
Cara: I hope so.
Oh I want to be a lion slash monkey.
John: Describe your friend Nat Wolff in three
words.
Cara: Rambunctious.
John: Yup.
Cara: Delicious.
John: Agree.
Cara: And nutritious.
John: Strongly agree.
Yeah.
Cara: Totally.
John: He's good to be around.
Cara: And funny too.
John: But not... he's less funny than he is
nutritious.
Cara: Yeah, I agree.
John: Would you rather the world contain a
puppy-sized elephant or an elephant-sized
puppy?
Cara: A puppy-sized elephant.
John: Yes!
Cara: Obviously.
John: What's your favorite fruit?
Cara: Passion fruit.
John: What is your favorite color?
Cara: Periwinkle blue.
John: And what is the meaning of life?
Cara: Love.
John: Thanks Cara.
Thanks for being in my video.
Cara: Thanks John.
John: So there you have it Hank.
Cara Delevingne likes my eyebrows and is an
octopus.
It occurs to me that I forgot to say "Good
Morning" to you in this video so Good Morning,
it's actually nighttime, but Good Morning!
And now having said that, I will see you on
Friday, when the Project for Awesome begins!
Links in the doobly-doo to all the Project
for Awesome stuff!
I'm so excited!
Goodbye!